one of my favorite people on the planet
and one of my favorite guests to have
here on the show a video that he did
with the Chiefs and Andy Reed playing
his brother Randy modern families finest
Eric Stonestreet good to see you sir
good to see you rich you're not invited
I did not get an invitation
it's amazing dad and you make all people
that don't get invited to something in
their lives feel way better about
themselves you know what it's it's it
was a great part of my life it was there
for seven years met Susie who you know
they're my kids or ESPN babies my career
started there and I have nothing but the
fondest of memories and lost your
address and they yes for 15 consecutive
ESPY Awards now 16 I think it's all good
you know I come out of the smoke Sunday
morning every day on the NFL Network
maybe that is something to do with
although they invited Tirico back and he
left he left as much they left just a
few years ago not any rate I'd take it
personally I do good I very much do what
a hilarious video that you put out
thanks man
yeah where you play Randy reader of Andy
Reid yeah you know started the idea
started if you like three or three or
four years ago kidding now long well
just the idea of it my friend Jerry
Collins who helped me on this boat a lot
of the stuff in the interviews and stuff
like that great guy we were back in
Kansas City and when we were leaving he
was like we should do something where
you play Andy Reid's brother and then
Randy Reed happened and then I said
something to mark Donovan about at the
president and the Chiefs and he was like
let's do it
but then this year Brett Veatch called
and was like do you want to do something
in Stadium and I was like I don't want
to really do anything in Stadium but you
had this idea and he was like done we're
doing this he rallied the troops Tyler
and Mike and the whole crew there the
Chiefs media and got coach Reed on board
which everybody loves Andy so I wanted
it to be a celebration of the Chiefs a
letter from me to the chief as to the
fans
just a fun little thing and then but
they did a great job they shot we shot
it in a day at training camp because it
looks like Hard Knocks that's what I
wanted it to look like I wanted it to
feel like real grounded
and the interactions with the players
and coach Reid grounds it and makes it
believable there are people that thought
it was not me really
yeah people tweeted me saying that you
know I bought into thinking it was not
right for Brandy's brother Randy's
brother
so during training camp yeah and you
read get how many hours do you give you
oh it's how would you say the times
yours hit no on the field the only rules
were you don't get ahead of the play
okay when they're out there practicing
yes and don't get in your coach because
I was very I'm a fan first rich you know
that I did not want to be in the way of
winning a Super Bowl there's a week one
loss Jacksonville Randy Reed got in the
way that was my biggest fear so I wanted
to just do this in us in the cinnamon
shadows and a lot of people didn't even
know I was there you know a lot of
players thought I was a coach I mean
Tyree kill when he saw me he thought I
was a coach on the field he was like I
thought you I thought you were coach
like so it from a distance there are
shots that you can't tell me people
wouldn't think it was in any way they
gave us full access and he signed off on
it Brett signed off on it they signed
off on it with the rule of stay away
from Andy which I'm like no problem I
don't want anywhere to be anywhere near
big red right and don't get ahead of the
play and just you know kind of don't get
in the huddle like it couldn't get in
the huddle right and they were doing
stuff at the end I could but but did you
feed lines to Kelsey yeah so I would
walk her to the guys and say like okay
I'm gonna come back don't do this or do
this say this but Kelsey isn't natural
he is I'm bombing Kelsey Kelsey coach
Reid and Brett Veatch all naturals Brett
Veatch delivering that line where he's
like a coach we don't want or need I
mean it's he does a great job and Andy
the thing I love is you see Andy's
personality there when I say I brought
ribs oh man like just how it's generally
excited he is and I just love that
people get to see Andy and that he was
willing to do it is so cool the guys did
a great job the the Chiefs
communications the content people shot
it right who edited oh dude it's get
this guy named Evan Miller great guy he
sat there and edited if they're used to
editing sports stuff you know clips of
things they know the parameters a lot of
time went into getting these cuts
because there's an hour and 15 minutes
of material that needed to be condensed
down to five minutes right they all work
their tail off they all work their tail
off and it's funny and it's available on
Eric's at Eric Stonestreet Instagram if
splitter it's out there everybody
everybody posted it yesterday yeah
that's a great way to just we're back
footballs back yeah it's just it's just
it feels makes it adds something special
yes to the fact that the Chiefs I just
wanted it to be a little fun thing and
now I want to I want to get in I just
want to win baby I just
oh that's somebody else's thing now I
know well that's the Raiders oh yeah I
mean the latest from Oakland which I
guess we should give to the rich eyes
and show listeners and viewers in case
you're just joining is that Antonio
Brown according to Joe Cena anderson of
ESPN had an emotional speech and apology
to his teammates cool and it looks like
he's gonna play monday night now really
it it looks like it's possible that he
plays monday night i don't know how we
get from from apologizing to the team i
assume an apology must be delivered to
the face of mike Mayock
yeah and some for you have to have some
form of monetary discipline here
otherwise otherwise it would simply be
we're rallying around him cursing out
the general manager and emotionally
apologizing for it and man that makes
him remember when we all came with a
team when Antonio came and apologized
for calling mike Mayock a cracker I mean
really I mean that's not like the Gipper
right here you know what I mean no they
got to figure that out I mean I enjoyed
watching hard knocks I'm a Jon Gruden
fan I think Jon Gruden so far yeah and I
love mike Mayock you know how much I
love mike Mayock right I'm actively
rooting against them when they play the
Chiefs I'm not rooting against them when
they're not playing against the Chiefs
just like I'm not rooting against
what's-his-name's team over there unless
they're playing the Chiefs
but you know I'm not a Rooter against
her but come on you know they got a they
got a set a standard here it's like you
can't just scream and yell at the
general manager and then one has to
think some some
form um next step before the ultimate
step of suiting him up in its monetary
thing of them suspending him if they
suspend him doesn't that void a
significant amount of his con well
there's all sorts of stuff that that
that that's out there his behavior to
this point does appear to be enough for
them to just void it right now
he's a great guy I heard he's a good
teammate when he's there I heard he's
fun and cool and his appearance on Hard
Knocks with all the kids all that is all
great I don't know if it's just all for
show or whatnot I mean I can't tell you
about your problem not my problem let's
talk more about the Chiefs okay now what
do you what do you want to know okay
um for everybody who has Damian Williams
and fantasy like me yep should I be
concerned about Sean McCoy Damian
Williams this is starting running back
at the Kansas City Chiefs and now and
and Darwin Thompson was our second
string and I think he's shifted down a
little bit because we signed I drafted
Sean McClure Sean McCoy as a bill with
my fantasy team first and now he's on my
roster right chief that but cuz again
I'm back by committee dude stop us we
you know how good LeSean McCoy is out of
the backfield yes Damian Williams great
on the back Darwyn Thompson this kid
amazing out of the backfield I can't
wait for a two back-to-back set baby and
now that meet Cole Hardman how much is
he gonna have anything I don't know I
think he's gonna be a great player I
think he's gonna develop into a great
player we drafted him drafted him when
it seemed like Tyree kill might not play
not well I'm dressed even though we did
not we the Chiefs the Chiefs believed in
Tyree kill from the beginning because
they had the full scope of the picture
that's not why we drafted Nicol Hardman
to my knowledge okay uh anyway yes we
have my co Harwin Kansas State Wildcats
are in Pringle our wide receivers boys
how you love you can't see well okay I
do I know you do and now Tyler lock it's
the number-one receiver love Tyler
Lockett it's soak up in Seattle right
now yep okay so what the thing about the
Chiefs that I want to see is the defense
I think you've got an upgrade in Frank
Clark with all due respect to D Ford and
Tyrann Mathieu in the back is he's done
I love that guy I mean one can play for
me he's one of those play he can play
for me tiny are on the field right and
he look at his snap count from the
Texans last year he's everywhere
and the way we're gonna use him with
spaags is defense I think is gonna be
phenomenal got two meats bags at
training camp as Randy read I did have
my mustache on when I talked to him and
he was very confused I introduced myself
as a dumbass there's a great out outtake
love this right of me talking to a
security guard on the field asking him
if any wild animals ever get up here on
this field he's like well not you know
not to my knowledge maybe at nighttime I
said well if a the wild animal gets up
here what would you do
it's like why tackle it wait good and so
but as I'm standing there this little
kid comes up he goes hey can I get your
autograph and I'm like I'm not doing
autographs right now kid and so I just
keep talking to this guy doing this bit
and then as I leave I say hey I'll sign
your thing now and I'm signing it and I
go you know I'm just dumb actor right
and he goes yeah yeah I know anything
important to do with the cheese so fun
but he acknowledged that I was in fact
just a dumb actor did you get my Holmes
again this is where the fan yeah Trump's
comedy right yes I just wanted to get in
there and get out and make it in same
with the release of it I just I wanted
to I wanted it out a little sooner than
it was look out but it's out now and
then I just want to win games I just I
just wanted to do something fun and I
was so thankful grateful that Brett
Brett let me tell you something right
now
cheese fans did you have Brett Beach the
GM the GM Brett Veatch is a great great
leader I give you the floor here so cuz
again you have some inside information
or insight just about how how I told him
the other works I'm talking to you on
the phone the general manager of my
favorite sports franchise ever and he's
not given I like I didn't know Tyreke
signed his deal like I learned that from
sure it's like everybody else I'm not
and I don't want that pressure of
knowing that kind of stuff wouldn't ask
for it but just the fact I told him I
said the fact that I'm taught as a 40
something year old man talking to the
general manager of the Kansas City
Chiefs is a dream come true like I can't
explain how much it means to me to have
them give me that access in that moment
you live your best life Eric Stonestreet
because you you're your buddy with the
goods well it's the Commission
Roger knew all about this video I sent
him a picture right after I did and he
was like whenever the Commissioner
updates on the on the set of Randy Ray
absolutely was he and he asked me for it
he's like what's going on with Randy
Reed and I said mom it's happening it's
happening swear swear because here but
here's the thing yes that speaks to who
Andy Reed is everyone loves Andy Reid
mm-hmm that has nothing to do with me
that has to do with the fact that I got
to go in and celebrate our head coach
who everyone loves well this is it don't
you think this is it for Andy this is
his chance oh for sure
this is [ __ ] I mean like it's time look
for Andy Reid they have the they have
the defending MVP who I believe is going
to be the first back-to-back MVP since
Peyton Manning I believe it I love you
Richard I truly believe it they have a
dynamic offense we just named pretty
Whedon even mentioned Sammy Watkins we'd
even mentioned his name Sammy Watkins is
healthy yeah he is stud we didn't
mention the line we and I know you love
your line well into your video oh yeah I
know okay and you also you know they've
got they've got the defense we have the
defense so this isn't Clark isn't is an
animal Christiane's is an animal those
guys up front Derick naughty
unfortunately we lost Breeland speaks
this year we got tano who's tano passio
is a huge dude and then you got Okafor
that's what I'm saying this is it but
they know how to line up properly right
yeah we know how to line up properly
okay you do know how to inflate them
properly that's right I remember now
science just just line it properly
that's all I'm asking we don't have that
problem anymore anymore anymore anymore
look I
I am very excited I will not miss a
Chiefs home game this year is that true
that is 100% check your schedule
I've everything's all set yes okay I
have flights booked in December to make
sure I'm correct with everything okay
yeah you're ready are you gonna be at
one of the games is anything on your
schedule
mm-hmm I got to London games that I'm
calling for the NFL networking otherwise
I'm just here in lost you know we were
just talking about you in Kansas City
the kid that was editing this he's
Fany errs and he he was like why doesn't
Rich Eisen call football games and I
said he should call football games
I appreciate Evan Evan and you I'm
calling to well Barney answers and
Texans Jags and in in the UK one in
Tottenham and one in Wembley it's coming
up are you gonna do English accent I am
game is right around when brexit might
happen and I'm like literally looking at
the news saying please push this thing
back because I know they're not gonna
settle it I love London know where he's
staying
oh it's amazing well you will talk we'll
talk about it here here's what we'll do
here Eric Stonestreet here on the Rich
Eisen show we will come back you have
got a news update Chris correct correct
I want to know like Julio Jones if
there's anything you could tell me on
that front there's so much what else do
you have over there to tease for the
listeners I so we can talk more Chiefs
we got some ratings from last night some
contract details and we got this crazy
story about Hugh Freeze just another
coach of Liberty who coached from a
hospital oh I saw that well there's now
there's an update to this no no no no
it's even more bizarre than get more
bizarre than coaching by hospital bed
it's shall Eric Stonestreet is here and
Craig Kilborn is making his way to the
studio for an hour number three visit
here on the first game already in the
books of the NFL season edition of the
Rich Eisen show good to see you back
here for another segment thank you this
is my Terry Crews impersonation you want
to see it what is that oh by the way I
like it what you're doing with your with
your pecs right now one thing before we
get to the news update what we have not
told you what the name of my fantasy
team name is with Chris Brockman oh no
you're gonna love this you're gonna like
it okay
last year was touch of the Vermeil like
because when you get a little misty odd
yep hmm this time around we decided even
though we wanted as touch of the Vermeil
we were gonna change it and it's based
on the photograph that the coaches took
at the NFL owners meeting this
March yes and it's based on Andy Reid
yes taking that right leg and that left
leg implanting it wherever the hell he
damn pleases and telling Sean McDermott
Sean McDermott to his right and Bryan
Flores to his left
come and try and bust up this man spread
centerpiece
those are redwoods and the name of our
team is man spread centerpiece and
you're looking at the avatar on the
screen that is incredible and we
couldn't help but notice when you were
sitting with Andy Reid as Randy oh yeah
he's sitting there as the man spread
centerpiece look at that right - hell
yeah I mean that's just the way he sits
I was off to this I was off that's two
benches as you don't know well it's like
the two arm rests in a plane seat like
they're there and you need to adjust
Andy Reid has ever sat in the middle
seat in his whole life
no I don't think so no I don't think not
on the way to the punt pass and kick
contest like yeah you know do you know
our show every once in a while yes by
the name of LaBonge I can't think of his
first name okay he was one of Chiefs at
one day I'm like wait Dubrow you cheese
fan he's like Andy Reid's my best friend
I'm like for real sure-enough Andy Reid
and this guy played football together
when I was there shooting the Randy read
stuff late at night I get a text message
from big red that's just a picture of
those guys as youth football players on
their on their team so it's amazing he
everyone loves Andy Reid everyone does
mooch loves him every single human being
that's come across him so everybody
should check out again the play gets him
in the playoffs because he always finds
word unbelievable this is our guest
we're celebrating a man I know get the
man spread centerpiece we got this man
spread look at you you're doing it too
but we all do it I mean it's it's an
alpha thing it's like you're the boss
I'm gonna take I'm gonna take the space
that's matter if I'm gonna spread it
okay let's get with Eric Stonestreet
here from Modern Family um part of our
show as always when I'd love when you
come here just uh you're just hanging
out I love it love it
me too let's get a news update brought
to you by Kris Brockman and
[Music]
with the news brought to you by the
Honda CRV stupendously stylish and
available with real-time all-wheel drive
the CRV is ready to team up for your
next adventure so hurry in to your local
Honda dealer today Christopher what do
you have okay just recapping the Antonio
Brown stuff from this morning
ESPN's Justina Anderson saying that a
source told her Antonio Brown issued an
emotional apology at a team meeting this
morning with captain's standing with him
Ian Rapoport followed that up saying
that he's hearing now there's a real
chance that not only does Antonio Brown
not get suspended but he actually plays
on Monday against Denver Wild time says
he and you're not wrong with that wild
times
okay there's and again I'll repeat one
more time there's got to be one more
step here there's got to be one more
step where he and Mayock what do you
want them to appear together a no no
conference it seems it should all be
behind the scenes that's the problem
with the tweet not what he tweeted it's
like take care of your business behind
closed doors the one who put it out
that's what I'm saying but don't you
think Antonio kind of owes it to Raider
fans to get out there and apologize
publicly I think what needs to be done
is a statement by the Raiders on behalf
of what teams are all about and on
behalf of their general manager that
some form of discipline is taking place
that he can apologize all he wants but
he does not play Monday Night Football
and he gets seed loses a game check
that's it and then we can all come
together as a family that's it and this
is the rule if you do something like
this we can't all just let bygones be
bygones because you're so terrific at
what you do that does not set a standard
for a single darn thing the probably
don't know what's happening behind the
scenes yeah I don't either
but the problem is we're putting
expectations that is putting
expectations on people that I don't
think they can fulfill because the NFL
is different than high school and
college football where if you screw up
you don't play what we have is the game
of football we're asking the NFL to do
the right thing which is be leaders in
show like poor behavior has
ramifications and repercussions you
don't get to play the game you love so
much I don't think they're gonna do it
because they all want to win games
because they all want to try to beat the
Chiefs which they won't what else over
there Chris Odell Beckham update for you
guys
Titans Browns big opening game for
Cleveland lots of hope expectations
oh no Beckham did practice full
participant Fridays doing with a hip
issue but he said had some quotes
yesterday it's like an extremely fast
car with the alignment off the car can
still go but it's dangerous when talking
about his oh my gosh so not able to open
it up he said yeah that's what he said
he's hoping that adrenaline would kick
in Freddie kitchens saying today though
that he's ready to go to go so we'll see
what Adele Titans - Taylor Lewan we're
not Tommy we're all focused on what
Jameis might look like with Bruce Arians
down in Tampa Mariota is on his I got
that starting running back who a Derek
Henry no I got him in the Tampa Bay oh
you got Peyton Barbour right yeah I mean
you've got you've got Mariota on his
walk here to here and no Taylor LaJuan
and here comes Myles Garrett in that
defense that does not bode well for the
Tennessee Titans in week number one
mm-hmm
but mister the trademark Ohio State
University coach of the Tennessee Titans
back to the state of Ohio where his
magic took place we'll see what happens
what Vrabel can cook up Matt Julio Jones
update gave kind of a bizarre press
conference yesterday where he talked
about may not being able to suit up on
Sunday against Minnesota then quickly
said he planned to play alluding to the
context of his contract situation but
then maybe he's injured Falcons
officially listed him as a not
practicing because of rest yesterday so
mm-hmm keep an eye on Julio Jones this
weekend okay as we mentioned earlier
Tyree kill three-year 54 million-dollar
extension with Kansas City Adam chef Ian
rapport noting that 35 million of it is
guaranteed albert bear has some details
on chair golf's massive contra
extension 25 million dollar signing
bonus for golf 57 million fully
guaranteed at signing 84 million dollars
in the first three years a hundred and
ten million dollars guaranteed against
injury what's the homes gonna get great
question already [ __ ] air I mean again
you just read golf
so I let's think about this it's gotta
be one hundred ten million guaranteed
it's gotta be what one 130-140 it
depends what DAC makes to cuz there's
gonna be a couple other quarterbacks
signed before him mmm-hmm but mo Holmes
is gonna be he could be the first I'm
chipping in I told him look it I've done
eleven seasons in the modern family I've
saved my money yeah I went in I'm
chipping in he's such a dream come true
man great guy that's what and again
every is pretty good that's what we
talked yesterday about the Jets and Sam
Donald and I'm like is it possible he
could be that guy did the Jets get their
dream come true in the draft day and I'm
just I'm just seeing so many other
franchises do it you got the stowed the
football gods decide to bestow Patrick
mahomes on here 30 years of not I'm just
going to say the same thing about
Patriots fans
I mean Patriots fans like my my my
nephews in New England no no seriously
that's all they know is they only know
the winning they don't know the 40 years
teams grow game it's a state alum who
Steve Grogan yes okay you know what I
mean like we could go all the way back
there were decades of that yeah
stay dumb baby yeah right Jared Stidham
hit'em know we're lucky there man
damn straight but I think I think the
we're not lucky it could be a two
hundred million dollar deal it's how
much it's gonna be real or not but yeah
just that if I'm you know I think it's
Leigh Steinberg I think he's gonna be
just to show me the money literally
worth every penny
dude's amazing yeah and and again we get
investing in a good dude that's why you
get him while we get
good right now do it do it you know it
by the end of the season at the end of
this season they should just do it for
somebody else sets the market and makes
it even more that's just the way I would
do it Thursday Night Football not a
great game 10/10 three final but the
ratings were great 15.3 overnight best
for an opening kickoff since 2016 but
even better than 2017 s Chiefs Pat's way
up from last year's Falcons Eagles did
you see Nick Saban do a commercial for a
flock did you I saw your tweet and
totally agreed with it if Nick Saban can
do a commercial for Aflac then tool and
whatever Alabama Crimson Tide player
that has the ability to make a
commercial should do it too you know
what I thought I thought about it I
thought of a thing
based on your tweet I thought of
something every day is that's compromise
is all these guys need to start putting
away money like 401 K s for these
players that never see the league that
never but come and give right and you
know start start a fund that starts
giving some of these guys a little money
after college or something like that
because what they pay Nick Saban to do
that is he you know I'm a free market
guy so he gets what he is whatever he
gets
but let's we gotta figure out a way to
get these guys something especially
since the commercials about him winning
championships he holds up his
championship rings they weren't they
were not they weren't Alabama rings oh
they weren't they looked like they were
just proper excuse me I'm not yeah I'm
not saying that they were real Alabama
rings I'm saying that the proper and of
course it looked like what you you know
he can get a did not play well did not
be Nick Saban that's not my point my
point is that he's won championships
that's the point that they were making
in the commercial and who's won the
championship players who are not allowed
to have a commercial airs so that's why
it was to me it was just like he's then
don't go play college football no no
that's no no no that's not that what do
you mean then don't play college
football know you can get you can get it
obviously a scholarship means something
you're getting a free education did some
take advantage of and some don't what
I'm saying is that he is coaching
college football he makes a heck of a
I don't begrudge him that he makes an
a-flat commercial me neither but why
should there be not an ad like if Aflac
wants to reach out and do the State Farm
wants to do an ad with tua why can't
your channel and it hurts or something
go ahead and why can't they defer the
money why can't they hire somebody to do
it and you can't take payment on it
until up you're out of call it should be
some form of that we don't know what
Nick Saban the agreement that he made
with that flat that's true there's no
begrudge I have no begrudge one thing
that the n-c-double-a does not allow a
student athlete who is famous enough and
talented enough to perhaps put in the
cell shoes put it perhaps put another
fake ring on his finger okay for the
next fake a flat commercial that they
should be allowed to do it yes if
somebody reaches out and wants to do
that like for instance if there is some
company right now
hypothetically let's say it's a leave
number no no no if there is a company
out there that say makes hospital beds
watch out to Hugh Freeze we got a deal
for you Hugh since clearly you coach
from one even though you got shut out
while in one I mean so wait his team
crapped the bed pan Eric Stonestreet
here's here's the latest on that here's
the latest on that so Pat forty of Yahoo
Sports had a story today so Liberty
spokesman told so he's still he's got
back surgery he's still in this bed I
not sure if he's gonna travel he does
beforehand we're showing the picture
you're laughing because it is absurd and
by the way I don't know if the coach's
next to him right there it does appear
like you're doing the same movement
right now Eric as that coach may be
trying to either call a play to make
sure that nobody's lip-reading or
laughing what what is the next step okay
so the rivers playing
going to Louisiana okay and the school
has purchased what it calls a medical
chair for him to use in the press box
that's a list here a source told Pat
forty that it's characterized as a
dental chair that kind of moves all
around up and down the school is not
calling it that but the chair is being
flown to Louisiana and installed in the
press box they're playing Louisiana
Lafayette on Friday did not have
assistant coaches exactly does he not
have anyone else that can do delegate
anything as opposed to hold arm in this
here's a chant I got the Liberty chant
for this week you ready give me an R or
give me an i what does that spell resign
rinse Oh so last week they rinse last
week he was in the hospital bed and they
kind of wheeled him in because it was
press box is set accessible the press
box at Cajun field in Louisiana
Lafayette was built in 1971 so that's
why they had to ship the chair down and
the hasta dental chair is easily fit
into the press box so this kind of we
bring it all full circle here right
don't pay the athletes don't do that no
there's not enough money for that but to
rent a or purchase and ship a dental
chair by air to Louisiana so he'll
freeze can coach from it we got money
for that oh yeah what's the budget for
that
what about face time that's a good one
too yeah just be at home on the couch
yeah I mean or however he hooked up that
press conference videoconference
assistant coach delegate delegate it's
not that a that's what a good head coach
does right is delegate oh my gosh
or wait a minute have the of all the
scripts for the final season of Modern
Family been completed no okay how about
Coach cam next episode is coach is a
coach cam episodes okay well that one's
already in the yeah
later on this season maybe the final
coach camp your coaching from a hospital
bed or from a dental chair because you
refuse to delegate to your assistant
coach yeah like ripped straight from the
Hugh Freeze this is a classic example
have modern family done this first so
people would be like the dumbest story
I've ever seen in my life it's like no
this is real no this is real Hugh Freeze
everybody you have one other item over
there that's it well I saw when I saw
Patricia riding around on a four-wheeler
yeah I knew he was hurt I was like
what's this guy this is not setting a
good example for big guys walk around a
little bit and then I saw he was hurt
and I was like I can't take not
respected his big sick-looking name
driving around on it oh man
this has been a blast oh man always
apply thank you for coming on cue for
today is red Friday in Kansas City which
is a cool tradition in Kansas City the
whole town turns red fountains in Kansas
City you know Kansas City has more
boulevards than Paris and more fountains
in Rome true story
that's a slow Google on it more and we
turn our fountains red the Hunts are
there just going all over the place and
it's a great tradition and I brought you
this flag oh look at this this is a gift
the red Friday flag well I'm gonna keep
it I'm not it's also upside down there
we go
1960 to 2060 seasons that's football the
English do you know how many working
fountains there are in Kansas City no
did you google it it's like 200 and some
probably 200 yep no list in the world
yeah did you google boulevards more
boulevards in Paris bro come on it's
just unfound there's definitely more
barbecue than Paris more barbecue yeah
did you see mr. Schwartz took the
barbecues smoked a bunch of meat took it
to all the press and fed the press the
other day he's just a good he's a good
kid
Kodiak by the way that's still one of my
favorite moments we're the network of
this ship not that work this show turns
five in October happy birthday thank you
one of my favorite exchanges in the
five-year history of this show was when
were in Kansas City for the big slick by
the way congratulations on another huge
do two million over two million this
week we Sandefur this history
unbelievable two million for Children's
Mercy Hospital in Kansas City we're in
we're in the the the big K right and
you're with Mitchell Schwartz and I'm
like remember the tribe and you go
Chiefs not that's right I was talking
about his Judaism not your football -
yeah but God bless your country thanks
for having me on Reggie got it 25th is
the return of Modern Family on ABC for
its final season final right there's no
turning back it's done I know of Modern
Family for sure and do we know how it
ends right now
no not at all no clearin you have a
mystery it's all mystery well what's
funny is we're shooting a shorter season
and the shorter season would end around
February so uh-huh uh-huh you know where
I'm going I do yeah
too much mm-hmm you say you don't go
unless you do makes it roll yeah I won't
be there unless they're there never what
a week that would be sir what a week
that would be Eric Stonestreet at Eric
Stonestreet on both Instagram and
Twitter Craig kill boards coming up when
we come back I stroll down it'll be
great I haven't seen him in forever in a
day but you're gonna probably see him in
back in the green never Adam okay well
that's about to end I believe about for
the TV audience we are going to show a
little bit of the Randy Andy Reed video
that Eric put out there into the
universe this week we come back we'll
stroll down memory lane courtesy of my
friends of super ol memory lane of
courtesy of my friends of courtyard
that's how we return thanks Jerry
Collins for Randy Reed for more of the
Rich Eisen show tune - audience Channel
239 on DirecTV for free on BR live or
download the Rich Eisen show app